Shireen Baratheon: The Dance of Dragons.
It's the story of the fight between Rhaenyra
Targaryen and her half-brother Aegon for control
of the Seven Kingdoms.
A True Telling by Grand Maester Munkun, being
a history of the war of Targaryen succession
between the Princess Rhaenyra and Aegon, Second
of his name, that nearly destroyed the realm.
Viserys Targaryen: One night, a servant found
the old king had died in his sleep.
Protocol dictated that the bells would be
rung and a raven sent to Dragonstone to summon
the heir, Princess Rhaenyra, for her coronation.
But Alicent had other plans.
Ser Otto Hightower, the Hand of the King and
father to Queen Alicent, demanded that the
succession be settled immediately.
The old king had forced the lords of Westeros
to swear fealty to Princess Rhaenyra as his
heir.
But Ser Criston Cole rightly pointed out that
a son comes before a daughter.
Shireen: Both of them thought they belonged
on the Iron Throne.
When people started declaring for one of them
or the other, their fight divided the kingdoms
in two.
Brothers fought brothers, dragons fought dragons.
By the time it was over, thousands were dead.
And it was a disaster for the Targaryens as
well.
They never truly recovered.
Varys: During the great Targaryen civil war
known as "the Dance of the Dragons," a king
and queen each vied for the throne, dividing
their house and its dragons against each other.
Eventually, the queen was fed to her rival's
dragons while her son watched, and the victorious
king soon died of his own wounds.
By the war's end, King's Landing was smashed,
cities razed and sacked never to be rebuilt,
and dragons had faded from this world.